[Music]
as a private contractor
you're possessing a unique set of
[Music]
skills what's that
i went up you said it was clear i said
the front was clear
um
front back right wrong
anyway shall we
[Music]
so what we got something rather nasty
has been stolen
we have to stop that getting onto the
open market
who's the buyer greg simmons the
billionaire armstealer
oh a lot very serious faces up here in
there you can't catch this fish with
conventional lures i'm sorry the lure
being daddy francesco
the movie style rick simmons favorite
movie sir and how do we get him
blackmail
who's to gear
very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you i'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law i actually love my
sister-in-law
just out of here you made that quite
[Music]
i'm ready let's go to work when someone
pinch me please is that danny francesca
what's next for dude i'm playing a
mysterious self-made billionaire you
just described me
shadow mate do whatever i do
whatever i do
whoever greg was buying from was amongst
you last night
i can get inside the ukrainians
i hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
you recognize your awesome fortune that
is a sexy name cover's blown we're burnt
what do i do the emergency is gonna melt
you stop danny francesco you stopped
what are you gonna do with that
so you weren't seen by anyone
yes
that's yes do you want seen by anyone
yes or yes you were seen by someone
yes
[Music]
you